quel smartphone acheter au mois de
septembre 2023 c'est un truc qui est
vraiment vraiment intéressant pourquoi
parce qu'il y a plein de nouveaux
smartphones sont sortis il y a pas
longtemps il y en a qui vont sortir dans
pas longtemps donc ça vaut pas le coup
d'acheter forcément les modèles
précédents on va commencer par les
smartphones à moins de 200 €. je vais
sélectionner deux produits qui me
paraissent être assez intéressant plutôt
on se rapprochant des 200 € qu'un peu
plus bas c'est la première marque ça va
être c'est Xiaomi ça va être le redmi
note 12 qui est une très bonne référence
on a un très bel écran à molette 120
Hertz ça marche bien on a de la recharge
rapide on est un peu moins de 200 balles
vous voyez
199,90 €, mais globalement ça fait le
taf la fiche technique est solide
derrière donc vous avez ce qu'il faut
pour venir jouer à des jeux pour avoir
de la fluidité l'expérience photo va
être pas folle même si Xiaomi vous dit
on a trois caméras dont un capteur
principal de 50 mégapixels c'est pas le
meilleur capteur du monde vous attendez
pas avoir des photos qui vont faire des
trucs de fou mais ça sera correct la
batterie est très grosse 5000 milliards
donc pour l'autonomie c'est bon pour
regarder des films des séries voyez vous
avez du Full HD plus c'est top ça marche
ça c'est un très très bien c'est une
très très belle référence le redmi note
12 vous le recommande une fois de plus
si lone c'est smartphone vous intéresse
je vous mets le lien juste en bas dans
la description autre smartphone que je
viens vous recommander c'est chez
Samsung la valeur sûre ça me saoule
c'est leader du marché c'est le Galaxy
A14 on est un peu dans la même idée très
grand écran de 6,6 pouces on est en full
HD+ de la même manière triple capteur
photo dont un capteur principal de 50
mégapixels une fois de plus ça a pas
faire de la magie ça va pas être
complètement dingue c'est un peu la même
fiche technique qu'on va retrouver un
peu partout avec un capteur principal de
50 mégapixels un ultra grand angle 5
mégapixel c'est pas fou de la macro ça
c'est globalement à pas grand chose et
une caméra de selfie qui sera pas folle
mais qui fera le boulot une batterie qui
à peu près de la même taille c'est les
4900 milliampères heure donc vous voyez
sont deux produits qui sont très très
similaires quasiment même tarif et si on
est à 199 euros la grosse différence
qu'il va y avoir c'est l'OS est-ce que
vous préférez l'expérience de Samsung
avec ONU eye ou est-ce que vous préférez
l'expérience de Xiaomi avec son redmi
note 12 dans sachant qu'ici on parle de
deux smartphones 4G ce ne sont pas des
smartphones 5G donc si vous voulez de la
5G on va monter sur les smartphones un
peu plus haut on va passer la la
barrière des 200 balles les deux modèles
moins plaisent bien je vais préférer
l'expérience logiciel de Samsung qui me
ferait basculer sur le Galaxy A14 mais à
vous de voir laquelle vous intéresse et
une fois de plus je vous mets les liens
juste en bas dans la description on va
passer la barrière des 200 euros on va
sur la catégorie 200 à 500 euros alors
soyons clairs plus vous allez mettre
d'argent et plus vous allez en voir chez
Samsung et les trucs qui sont super
intéressants le A14 4G je vous l'ai
montré on était un peu moins de 200
balles si vous voulez le modèle 5G on
passe à 249 euros on est quasiment sur
le même smartphone on aura à peu près
les mêmes rendus mais on aura de la 5G
si après on veut aller un poil plus haut
et bien je vous recommande le a34-5g on
arrive à 349 € c'est un petit peu un peu
plus haut tout de suite un tarif ça
raconte pas taper la même histoire mais
il va être assez cool ce smartphone
pourquoi et bien parce qu'on veut venir
augmenter au niveau de la qualité des
photos on est toujours sur une dalle de
6,6 pouces c'est du Super AMOLED 120 ça
va très très bien l'autonomie sera
excellente mais il sera un peu meilleur
au niveau des photos globalement ce
qu'il faut venir retenir du A34 5G après
pour moi le smartphone qui est le plus
cool chez Samsung dans cette gamme de
prix super rapport qualité prix c'est le
A54 5g et si vous regardez il y a une
promo tout de suite chez Samsung
normalement il y a 449 euros il tombe à
429 euros on économise 20 balles c'est
toujours cette prime et ce qui est bien
avec ce smartphone c'est qu'ils viennent
augmenter vraiment la qualité photo sera
bien meilleure là-dessus sur la 5G bien
évidemment toujours un grand écran
toujours un peu les mêmes tailles
d'écran de façon à 6,4 6,5 même dalle
Super AMOLED ça envahir ok le capteur
sera meilleur un peu plus loin également
sur l'ultra grand-angle la macro ça sert
toujours à rien en 5 mégapixels la
caméra de selfie sera un peu meilleur
mais l'expérience sera un peu plus cool
alors j'ai vu un autre truc qui est
super cool et un super bon plan que j'ai
trouvé sur le site de Samsung je tiens
le préciser cette vidéo des sponsorisée
par aucune marque aucune c'est vraiment
moi qui suis venu gratter et qui vous
dit ce qu'il en est j'ai trouvé sur la
gamme S vous avez un truc qui est pas
mal la gamme S c'est la gamme de la
photo et de la vidéo c'est le plus haut
de gamme chez Samsung et il y a un
modèle de l'année dernière si je dis pas
de bêtises c'est le s21f 5G bien
évidemment qui coûtait 759 euros qui a
peu vieux comme modèle mais qui est
encore assez cool qui tombe à 399 euros
ce qui fait qu'il est un peu plus cher
que le A34 il est un peu moins cher que
le A54 mais pour autant vous avez un
appareil photo qui est très très cool un
bloc photo qui est très très cool et qui
peut vraiment être un super rapport
qualité-prix une arriver à faire à faire
en septembre 2023 ce qui est cool c'est
que en termes de qualité d'écran on sera
au dessus vous êtes sur la technologie
dynamique à molette 2x de Samsung qui
est juste topissime taux de
rafraîchissement sans verre ok dynamique
full acheter plus bon ok ça fonctionne
au niveau des photos vous avez un 12
mégapixels sur le grand angle ça fera le
taf des fois il vaut mieux et je vous le
dis regardez ne serait-ce que ce qu'on
voit sur les fiches techniques il vaut
mieux avoir un bon 12 mégapixels qu'un
50 mégapixels un petit peu un petit peu
moyen c'est un super smartphone et qui
même s'il a pas la dernière puce et bien
est vraiment positionné un tarif
tellement intéressant qu'il fallait que
je vous le présente après si vous voulez
plutôt un Xiaomi que vous aimez la
marque Xiaomi vous avez le redmi de 12
5G qui est assez cool également
269 euros 90 très bon rapport qualité
prix fiche technique hyper boosté vous
voyez vous avez un écran à molette 120
Hertz la recharge rapide bon le proche
va très très bien également on reste un
peu dans la même idée que ce qu'on a
avec l'autre modèle mais un peu plus
boosté parce que le pros permet d'avoir
de la 5G ici très grosse batterie de
5000 milliards bon il y a une différence
au niveau des capteurs une fois de plus
les photos vont pas être folle folle
mais ça fera le taf alors après bien un
petit peu brouillé les pistes vous avez
le redmi de note 12 Pro qui ira une fois
de plus un poil plus loin avec une
meilleure Captor de Sony c'est lié mx766
qui est à stabilisablement et qui est
très cool donc vraiment augmenter la
qualité des photos on augmente également
le tarif 349 € 90 c'est un peu
l'équivalent du Galaxy A34 du côté de
chez Xiaomi et après ils ont un autre
modèle le redmi note 12 Pro plus 5G qui
vient plus concurrencer le Galaxy a54-5g
qu'on a du côté de chez Samsung avec une
caméra de 200 mégapixels bon voilà deux
points qui vendent un petit peu
l'histoire c'est du marketing WHY NOT
vous avez de la charge très rapide 120
watts la fiche technique est hyper
solide donc si vous voulez un smartphone
qui se charge plus vite que le
smartphone de Samsung et bien vous
pouvez aller sur le redmi note 12 Pro
plus 5G après si vous êtes plus gaming
et que vous voulez un smartphone orienté
gaming un tarif maîtrisé on va aller
voir du côté de chez Coco une fois de
plus tous les smartphones dont je vous
parle ici sont des smartphones que j'ai
testé j'ai eu entre les mains que je
connais il y a énormément de produits
que je n'ai pas eu différentes marques
donc j'ai pas en parler j'ai pas prendre
la parole là-dessus je ne vous parle que
de produits que j'ai eu et que je
connais et que j'ai pu tester là on va
aller voir le poco le x55g qui est à
249,90 € autant en photo ça va être naze
soyons clair ça va vraiment pas être
terrible par contre en terme de
performance vous avez vraiment ce qu'il
faut et qui va aller assez loin qui est
très cool pour l'expérience de gaming
écran à molette full HD+ en verre c'est
un grand classique ça marche le stand
dragonne 695 qui est cool et qui va bien
de la recharge rapide bon la caméra on
s'en fout mais en fait ce qu'on va
rechercher ici vraiment c'est de la
performance et de l'expérience gaming à
molette c'est lolette c'est très cool en
terme de qualité d'écran vous avez ce
qui va après il vous montre un petit peu
autre résolution tactile bon voilà c'est
très précis c'est très performant ça
marche bien donc c'est vraiment une
fiche technique qui va moins être
orientée gaming c'est si on veut aller
un peu plus loin et qu'on a un peu plus
de budget vous allez sur la version Pro
299,90 on rajoute 50 balles de plus là
vous êtes sur un processeur un peu plus
performant Snapdragon
778g c'est la série gaming de Qualcomm
et qui conviendra bien l'écran c'est
sensiblement la la même chose de la
molette d'autres display ça veut dire
qu'il a un peu percé pour la caméra mais
c'est la même chose pour l'acheter plus
en verre c'est la même chose la caméra
sera un peu meilleure mais de toute
façon je sais pas quoi les photos c'est
pas foufou après je vais rentrer plus
dans le côté design avec un smartphone
que je trouve très bien designé super
joli un tarif extrêmement maîtrisé cette
fois-ci on va du côté de chez Honor on
va sur le Honor Magic 5 Lite alors
regardez il y a une promo sur ce
smartphone là j'ai vu normalement il
coûte 329,90 € là il est à
299,90 qui est quand même plutôt assez
cool que j'aime bien elle travaille de
Honor si ils ont vraiment fait un super
travail au nord ces dernières années
c'est ce design vous avez vraiment à
côté symétrique au niveau du dos qui est
super joli et cet écran qui va être
incurvé sur les côtés et qui est aussi
super mignon alors après c'est un peu la
même histoire on est sur l'olyte 120
Hertz batterie 5100 milliampères heure
c'est un peu la même chose que les
autres une techno de rame turbo qui
permet d'avoir 8 Go de RAM + 5 giga qui
va se prendre au niveau du stockage au
niveau du rhum pour vous libérer si vous
avez de la place ça va venir dans la
rame pas mal pour aussi pour le gaming
caméra bon ok c'est pas là une fois de
plus on va voir les meilleures photos la
gamme Magic 5 elle est très cool sur le
Magic 5 Pro sur Magic 5 Lite c'est pas
mal je peux mettre commencer à arriver
mais ce que j'aime beaucoup c'est cet
écran incurvé qui est super joli donc si
vous voulez un produit designé un tarif
très maîtrisé vous pouvez y aller vous
serez pas déçu il est assez lumineux il
est correct il marche bien il y a de la
performance on va faire des caisses
c'est efficace donc on peut venir jouer
aussi dessus il y a pas de souci il y a
plein de techno très cool qui vous
mettent ici pour la protection des yeux
donc bon voilà c'est un smartphone qui
est très très sérieux super fiche
technique donc si vous voulez un
smartphone sympa designé et un tarif
très maîtrisé vous pouvez aller sur le
Honor Magic 5 Lite alors on va augmenter
un petit peu en tarif du côté de chez
Honor un autre smartphone que j'aime
bien qui est un peu moins dans le côté
design et très rigolo c'est le Honor 90
mais qui a quand même assez cool vous
voyez on a ce bloc photo qui est décalé
sur le côté on perd un peu le côté
symétrie l'écran un super résultat chez
dxmark l'appareil photo est très quali
200 mégapixels dans cette gamme de prix
c'est bien et il coûte celui-là
normalement écoutez alors il était un
peu plus cher mais il y a un mot qui
permet de le passer en dessous des 500
euros il coûtait 599 € 90 et là il est à
499 euros 90 c'est sorti il y a pas très
longtemps donc il reste très très très
très actuel il y a un écran de 6,7
pouces c'est très très grand snap dragon
7 gène 1 ça ira parfaitement bien donc
pour faire tourner vos jeux tout ce que
vous voulez dessus aucun problème c'est
un super super super smartphone mais
voyez il est un petit peu en dessous des
500 euros et c'est pas forcément le
meilleur rapport qualité-prix qu'on peut
avoir ici coup ça vaut le coup de venir
se poser la question d'aller chez
Samsung sur le S21 et feu que je vous ai
montré tout à l'heure qui est hyper
intéressant au niveau de la photo donc
si vous voulez vraiment de la photo vous
pouvez aller sur ce smartphone là alors
après j'en ai d'autres regardez si vous
voulez vraiment être dans le design on
va aller chez nothing avec pas son phone
tout qui sont sortis il y a pas
longtemps le phone 2 qui est un peu plus
cher c'est le fun one qui reste super
joli avec la glyphen café avec toutes
ces ce côté lumineux parallèle qui est
super joli à l'arrière et qu'on arrive
aujourd'hui à toucher un tarif super
intéressant
399 euros pour avoir un smartphone très
différenciant alors les sont pas aussi
bonnes que sur la deuxième version du
modèle l'expérience nosting os qu'on va
retrouver ici également avec la version
2 je crois qu'on retrouve aussi qui doit
être mis à jour l'appareil photo qui est
correct qui est pas magique mais qui est
correct également et c'est un smartphone
il est intéressant parce que tarif est
très maîtrisé un peu moins de 400 € pour
avoir un smartphone hyper designé super
joli qui raconte une histoire qui est
très très cool alors j'ai un autre
smartphone que je vous ai recommandé au
mois de juin mais que je peux plus
revenir
au commande Xiaomi 12
t Xiaomi va pas tarder à sortir c'est
son calendrier donc ça va arriver par là
sa nouvelle version avec son chien
mitresse t est-ce que ça vaut le coup
d'acheter un Xiaomi 12 thé aujourd'hui
je suis pas extrêmement convaincu même
si on peut le trouver si vous intéresse
il est plus dispo chez Xiaomi mais on
peut le trouver chez Darty au lieu de
599 il trouve à 479 je me dis qu'il vaut
mieux aller sur un redmi note 12 Pro
plus que sur un Xiaomi 12 t je vous dis
le 13 c'était pas tarder à sortir donc
bon je suis pas sûr d'aller dessus
aujourd'hui après on passe un peu au
dessus dans la catégorie 500 à 900 euros
on peut en mettre un peu plus alors le
premier smartphone que je vais vous
montrer il est légèrement au dessus des
500 euros donc si vous avez un budget un
peu en dessous des 500 balles ça vaut
vraiment le coup de venir se poser la
question c'est du côté de chez Google
c'est le pixel 7a alors Google si vous
connaissez pas trop elle veut vraiment
faire un travail un peu à part des
autres ce qu'ils veulent mettre en avant
c'est l'expérience Google toute
l'expérience que vous allez avoir avec
tous les produits Google ça peut être
des produits pour la maison avec les
produits nest avec une tablette ça peut
être avec les nestomacs avec toute votre
domotique à la maison on à moins être
orienté performance brute comme on peut
retrouver sur certains smartphones avec
des processeurs Qualcomm ici c'est une
puce maison c'est la tensor G2 qu'on
trouve et qui est plutôt cool mais qui a
moins ce côté performance un peu hyper
hyper robuste sur le gaming par contre
sur tout le reste tous les usages c'est
orienté pour Google c'est avec une gomme
magique sur vos photos pour supprimer
quelqu'un enfin bref il y a tout ce
travail optimisé pour Google par Google
et qui est cool donc si vous aimez
Google si vous aimez l'expérience Google
509 euros le pixel 7a est très bon en
photo avec tout ce qu'on appelle la
photographie computationnelle derrière
c'est à dire toute l'intelligence
artificielle que Google peut vous donner
au travers du traitement d'image donc
vous prenez votre photo elle est cool et
elle est sublimée derrière on voit
l'algo qui bosse et ça c'est vachement
bien donc vous le retrouvez ici avec le
pixel Seta 100% Google sans compromis ce
qui est cool c'est qu'effectivement
alors vous avez tout Google la puce
tensorgé de qu'on a là il y a tous les
outils Google et c'est vraiment ce
qu'ils vont mettre en avant la
traduction en temps réel un smartphone
qui est aussi assez sympa très joli
l'écran il est assez cool en photo c'est
bombe atomique soyons clairs un tarif
très maîtrisé s'il y a un smartphone
qu'il faut venir recommander dans cette
gamme de tarifs en termes de photos un
excellent photophone c'est le pixel 7a
c'est il est au-dessus des autres après
si on veut aller un peu plus loin on
peut aller plus loin avec d'autres
smartphones mais sur des budgets
beaucoup plus élevés le pixel CETA il
est vraiment incroyable alors après il y
en a d'autres il y a le pixel 7 649
euros il y a le pixel 7 Pro on va aller
plus loin au niveau de la photo ça sera
exactement la même puce dans un cas
comme dans l'autre donc que vous aussi
sur le Seta le 7 ou 7 Pro vous avez la
même puce la même expérience logiciel
intérieur la différence va se faire
surtout au niveau des capteurs que vous
allez avoir et vous allez aller plus
loin bien évidemment avec le modèle Pro
la taille d'écran également 6,1 pour le
7a 6,3 pour le 7 et 6,7 pour le modèle
Pro la différence qu'on va avoir
également et bien c'est que ce soit
modèle Pro vous avez une dalle ltpo qui
permet d'avoir un taux de
rafraîchissement variable qui part de 1
à F donc une image par seconde lorsque
vous êtes sur un always on display par
exemple et qui peut monter jusqu'à 120
Hertz donc ça sera meilleur pour
l'autonomie ce
[Musique]
800 du moment le stand dragon 8 gène 2
qui est super bien Technodrome c'est
hyper résistant également j'ai du mal
avec mes mots sérieux sur l'île
résistant c'est de la payer des r5x 8 Go
de RAM sur la version de base ça va très
très bien vous avez l'UFR 4.0 en termes
de stockage bref elle est techno qui
sont super bonnes un écran AMOLED
pouvait y aller les yeux fermés si vous
cherchez un smartphone avec un petit
format le zenfone 10 est imbattable
là-dessus après un de mes coups de cœur
cette année ça va arriver du côté de
Nothing avec son phone 2 faut tout à 679
euros je le trouve magnifique même s'il
a un peu le même look and feel que la
version 1 il est vraiment beaucoup mieux
fini il est super joli il a glissenter
face est top nothing OS 2.0 et
magnifique en terme de photos ça marche
vachement bien et puis une fois de plus
voilà il y a vraiment une histoire qui
est différente qui raconte ce smartphone
c'est un smartphone un peu plus niché
mais si vous voulez un produit que les
autres n'ont pas vraiment vous pouvez
aller sur le dossier fun sans aucun et
une fois de plus je vous mets tous les
liens juste en bas dans la description
après pour avoir une des références ici
ça va rester Samsung avec son Galaxy S23
parce qu'il faut faire vachement de mal
aux autres
849 euros ce qui fait qu'il est quand
même vachement bien positionné il est un
peu plus cher que le nothing phone mais
bon on va pas venir raconter la même
histoire vous voyez les amis plus
classique c'est pas tout à fait le même
produit j'ai plus regardé par rapport à
ce que je vois chez Motorola avec un S40
pro qui est un smartphone intéressant
mais qui va être un peu plus cher qui
lui est à 899 euros et les 50 euros plus
cher et qui au niveau du bloc photo sera
quand même largement en dessous même si
le smartphone est très cool et même s'il
est très joli même si le design est très
sympa mais donc un moment si on doit
faire un choix entre le Edge 40 pro de
Motorola et le Galaxy S23 clairement on
va sur galaxy S23 de la même manière si
vous venez comparer par rapport à un
Xiaomi 13 qui a
999,90 €. je vais pas aller sur le
Xiaomi 13 je vais aller sur le Galaxy
S23 juste pour une question de tarif je
suis 150 balles moins cher quand même un
moment aller là-dessus ça me paraît un
peu plus cool ce c'est cool c'est qu'en
plus ici sont venus mettre le processeur
de Qualcomm on n'est pas sur un
processeur de Samsung donc extrêmement
performant vous avez une super dalle
dynamique à molette 2x c'est top Samsung
est top au niveau de la fabrication de
ses écrans les capteurs photos sont très
très bons il y a de la performance vous
avez toutes les ha du syndr dragon 8e de
derrière qui permet d'avoir de superbes
images on aura le même processeur soyons
clairs chez Xiaomi mais pas en même
tarif vous voyez donc c'est probablement
l'un des vrais bons plans à ce tarif là
enfin en tout cas dans cette gamme de
tarif là après si on reste dans cette
gamme des 500 à 900 balles et que vous
aimez iOS on va aller voir du côté de
chez Apple ce qui se passe sur un design
un peu old school soyons clair on a
l'iPhone se on va prendre notre temps
parce que là on est au mois de septembre
et Apple va venir lancer ses nouveaux
produits ils les annonce je sais pas
encore ouvrir cette vidéo mais ils
sortent le 12 septembre moi je fais
cette vidéo on est tous fin août ça vaut
le coup d'attendre un petit peu parce
que même si vous voulez acheter l'iPhone
se qui est sorti je crois que c'était
l'année dernière je peux pas vous dire
de bêtises là-dessus on est à partir de
559 euros donc moi ça me pose pas de
problème au niveau du tarif mais qui
vont pas venir en sortir un autre d'ici
quelques temps d'ici quelques jours je
serai vous j'attendrai même si un truc
est super intéressant avec les iPhone
c'est que il garde ce qu'on appelle une
valeur résiduelle très élevée ce qui
fait que si vous venez acheter un iPhone
par exemple là je vous prends l'iPhone
12 qui est proposé à 8009 € alors je
pense que l'iPhone 12 va sortir du
catalogue d'Apple et que l'iPhone 13 va
descendre à 809 euros et l'iPhone 12 lui
il va dégager mais par contre si vous
achetez votre iPhone 12 à 809 euros et
bien il viendrait quand même une valeur
assez élevée l'année prochaine cette
fameuse valeur résiduelle qui fait que
vous perdez pas trop d'argent si vous
achetez un smartphone de Samsung la
valeur résiduelle va énormément baisser
il vous prendrez votre smartphone
beaucoup moins cher donc en fait vous
perdez moins d'argent en achetant un
iPhone qu'en achetant un smartphone sur
Android ce serait patient avant
d'acheter un iphone 12 parce qu'il se
peut que je retrouve l'iPhone 13 à 800 9
euros d'ici à peine 15 jours on passe
au-dessus des 900 balles là on est dans
le haut du panier on se dit que tout le
monde est plutôt bon et que tous les
smartphones sont potentiellement
achetable c'est pas réellement vrai
souvent par rapport à une question de
tarif les tarifs évoluent des gros
smartphones comme Samsung et Xiaomi sont
présentés en début d'année on est en
milieu d'année donc les tarifs ont bougé
les curseurs sont modifiés et il y a
certains trucs qui valent encore le coup
et d'autres non donc au dessus de 900
balles vous voyez et bien chez Samsung
on va arriver sur le Galaxy S23 plus
1109 € et vous avez à côté un tarif qui
est quand même assez proche dans cette
gamme de prix soyons clairs le Galaxy
S23 ultra ça fait rajouter 150 euros 150
euros c'est beaucoup d'argent mais quand
on met 1000 euros dans son smartphone ça
vaut le coup de se poser la question ici
pour moi c'est clair si vous avez la
capacité de financement d'un smartphone
la plus mille balles j'irai pas sur le
Galaxy S23 plus j'irai directement sur
le Galaxy S23 ultra qui est mon coup de
cœur en tout cas pour l'instant en ce
début d'année notamment au niveau de la
photo c'est juste un smartphone qui est
dingue que j'adore il est juste là c'est
vraiment un excellent smartphone alors
en plus d'avoir un spln ça vous
intéresse d'avoir un stylet pour bien
griffonner sur votre smartphone
peut-être pas mais en termes de photos
il a une douceur il est magnifique le
rendu incroyable si vous avez la
capacité financière de mettre 1259 euros
au lieu de 1109 euros sur un S23 plus
allez directement sur galaxy S23 ultra
c'est beaucoup d'argent mais il est
absolument incroyable le seul qui pour
moi peut venir concurrencer aujourd'hui
ça va être du côté de chez Honor ça va
être sur le Honor Magic 5 Pro il est
aussi bon photo mais il manque un petit
truc ça reste la petite partie vous
savez un petit côté émotionnel je vais
préférer le rendu que va dégager le
Galaxy S23 ultra par rapport aux normes
Magic 5 Pro mais j'adore réellement ce
que propose mais Honor Magic 5 Pro alors
vous allez voir qu'en termes de tarif
c'est quand même réellement similaire on
est à 1199 euros 90 on est un petit peu
moins de 1200 balles un peu moins cher
que le Galaxy S23 ultra mais c'est un
super smartphone ce que j'aime
énormément sur le Honor Magic 5 Pro qui
est quand même cher c'est l'eau du
panier le design est cool l'écran qui
est incurvé est juste magnifique
effectivement un top scores d'examen
l'expérience logiciel aussi est
vachement bien voilà c'est une petite
bombe atomique donc
si vous devez faire votre choix entre
l'un et l'autre je vous dirai aller sur
le Galaxy S23 ultra mais si vous
préférez le design qu'on retrouve du
côté de chez Honor peut-être faut-il
aller sur le Honor Magic 5 Pro ça c'est
vraiment à vous de voir ce que vous
préférez et leur autre truc qui est
super intéressant il faut être plus chez
Samsung j'en reviens là-dessus c'est à
dire que vous avez un Galaxy S23 ultra
vous voyez à 1259 € et je vous dis une
fois de plus le Galaxy S23 plus à 1109 €
et ben moi ce que je vous recommande à
ce moment là si vous avez 1109 euros et
que vous voulez pas aller sur le Galaxy
S23 ultra parce que vous le trouvez un
peu gros et un peu massif il est super
gros dans la main il est énorme c'est un
très très gros smartphone et un truc un
petit peu plus petit et bien vous allez
sur le Galaxy Z flip 5 qui coûte 1199
euros un peu la même histoire mais
vraiment il est génial le format est
forcément plus petit et moi je vous le
dis Franck biais c'est devenu mon
téléphone principal j'ai enlevé la carte
SIM de mon iPhone et j'utilise depuis
quelques semaines maintenant uniquement
le Galaxy Z flip 5 et j'en suis supra
content le format est tellement petit
que c'est vraiment hyper hyper agréable
donc vous voyez on a un petit truc dans
la main ça c'est cool dans un sac ça
passe partout c'est un peu cher 1199
euros mais ça reste un excellent
smartphone ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
c'est plus compliqué de vous recommander
le Galaxy Z flip 4 même si il était bien
parce que vous avez un écran tellement
plus petit c'était l'écran tellement
plus grand écran externe sur le Galaxy Z
flip 5 va vraiment changer la façon de
revenir l'utiliser que je vous le
recommande vraiment donc si vous voulez
un petit format que vous avez un gros
budget allez-y après on ira pas aussi
loin en photo soyons clair attention sur
un zip 5 sur un Galaxy S23 ultra mais
bon voilà il faut savoir aussi qui est
censé priorités ce qui fait que je suis
vachement merdé le Xiaomi tresse pro à
1299 €, je peux pas venir vous le
recommander je trouve déjà plus cher que
mon galaxy S23 ultra en termes de photos
même s'il est très bon il va moins
m'emporter m'emmener loin donc à des
budgets comme cela j'irai chez ça nous
sauve sur son Galaxy S23 ultra et même
le Xiaomi 13 qui est cool il est quand
même beaucoup plus cher que le Galaxy
S23 donc pour moi là-dessus de fait et
par rapport au tarif Xiaomi et
disqualifié même si ils ont un super
bloc photo avec un très bon travail qui
a été fait avec Leica j'irai plutôt chez
Samsung sur cette gamme de produits en
tout cas et puis on retourne dans cette
gamme de prix un peu élevé si je dois
regarder ce qui se passe du côté de chez
Apple j'attendrai une fois de plus parce
que les iPhone voyez iPhone 14 avec 14
plus à 14 fois 114 pro max vous avez
dans quelques jours les iPhone 15 qui
vont être présentés les iPhone 14 vont
baisser en termes de tarif il se peut
qu'il y a des changements il se peut que
les tarifs sont aussi un peu plus élevés
avec potentiellement l'arrivée d'une
gamme Ultra soit c'est un changement de
nom pour le Promax qui va arriver en
Ultra soit vraiment y avoir en plus de
ça un iPhone 15 ultra encore plus
performant j'attendrai sérieusement
vraiment et on en reparle au mois
d'octobre dans quel smartphone acheter
au mois d'octobre 2023 et après si vous
êtes un gros budget que vous voulez le
smartphone de gaming le meilleur et bien
on va aller chez Asus sur le rockfon 7
alors il y a plein de produits rock VF
27 celui
Motorola avec son Razer 40 ultra autant
au mois de juin je vous ai dit allez-y
c'est un super smartphone on n'a pas de
smartphone avec des écrans aussi grands
alors on n'a pas aujourd'hui c'est vrai
de smartphone avec des écrans aussi
grands parce que ce qu'on a du côté de
chez Samsung sur le Netflix et bien
c'est que vous voyez on a quand même une
petite partie noire sur le bas qui
englobe pas la caméra là où Motorola va
venir englober la caméra donc c'est
quand même super cool mais le tarif fait
que ça devient un peu plus difficile de
vous le recommander on est exactement au
même tarif que le zflip 5 de Samsung
1199 euros autant le smartphone de moto
est très cool autant les finitions
seront meilleures sur le smartphone de
Samsung ça se joue à la qualité des
photos ça se joue à de la finition mais
si je dois préférer le travail au niveau
de l'écran externe j'ai préféré celui de
Motorola parce que on va venir englober
un peu plus l'écran mais le boulot
logiciel qui a fait Samsung et c'est là
où on voit que c'est le leader du marché
et bien c'est que ils vont aller plus
loin que ce que propose aujourd'hui une
moto sur son smartphone donc bon s'il y
a un smartphone à venir choisir
aujourd'hui qui se plie format ZIP c'est
le Galaxy Z flip 5 même si j'ai vraiment
une grosse mention coup de coeur sur le
Motorola Razer 48 ultra voilà ça fait
une très grosse vidéo mais je vous donne
ma vision sur ce qu'il faut venir faire
aujourd'hui et ne pas faire pour venir
choisir son smartphone dans les
meilleures conditions en septembre 2023
une fois de plus je vous mets un lien
juste en bas dans la description on se
retrouve en octobre 2023 pour la même
vidéo mise à jour avec normalement les
nouveautés d'Apple ça c'est sûr et
certain normalement les nouveautés de
Xiaomi va remettre un petit peu à jour
tout ça et vous allez voir que ah
peut-être des choix un peu différents à
ce moment-là en attendant je vous invite
quand même à venir découvrir toutes les
astuces que je vous donne pour venir
utiliser ce Galaxy Z flip 5 de Samsung
ça vous aidera peut-être à bien vous
décider la vidéo est juste là pour
essayer d'avoir vous serez pas déçu